you know i love jen sake uh she was
doing her white house press briefing and
one thing you know you have to keep in
mind as you watch the videos of john
saki look how miserable she looks but
you really got to see the misery in her
face because i think that over time if
you lie and lie and lie and then if you
lie about that then eventually it will
start making it so that your face will
actually be sliding off your skull gen
sucking inflation sure
today the president blamed putin's
invasion of ukraine for not just higher
gas prices but also higher food prices
uh inflation was at 7.4 in january for
the invasion uh in february it went up
to 7.9 putin didn't invade until the
24th so march is really going to show
the impact of the invasion and that
report doesn't even come out until april
12th so how are people supposed to
believe
the putin price hike is to blame for
food prices going up when the timeline
doesn't add up well here's what the
president is reflecting on one the the
price of gas has gone up by
approximately a dollar or more
since uh putin started lining up troops
at the border this is something that
outside economists have spoken to as
well not just the administration and
those are just factual details about how
much the price of gas has gone up we
know that's a huge impact
and when you say inflation people think
the cost on their pocketbook and the
impact on their budgets the second piece
on the availability of food we know that
different markets around the world are
impacted uh by uh by the lack of
production in ukraine and other because
of the war and we know that that could
impact global food
prices this is the first time we've
heard the president blame putin for
higher food prices i think what the
president's looking at is what the
impact has been in a lot of areas that
are leading to
price increases on people's pocket books
and where we could see it increasing
over the course of time okay so let's do
the second part first the food stuff now
remember before when i said that there
was this like slow motion lead to the
war and you all remember that hopefully
when biden just for weeks kept saying
you know okay he's gonna go in or we
think he's going to go in and he's about
to go in how come nobody in mainstream
media none of our political elite or any
of our trustworthy sources were warning
us that if we did anything related to
ukraine that food was going to go up
because you think maybe
we would have had a discussion about
that because i don't think the average
person likes when they go to the store
and they see the prices of food
exploding which we all know is happening
right now you do not need me to tell you
that just go to your store whatever your
stories go and does stuff seem more
expensive and are there less things on
the shelves pretty much everywhere the
answer is yes so she's just this idea
that they didn't know that food was
gonna rise or what was gonna happen if
we did anything in ukraine okay that's
just nonsense and then of course she
lies through a mission on the first part
related to gas because she says that you
know since the war price of gas has gone
up by about a dollar and that actually
is true
what she forgets to tell you and we've
covered this a bajillion times the price
of gas when joe biden became president
in january of 2021 was two dollars and
42 cents the average price of gas
in february of 2022 so a year later but
before ukraine
it was up
3.61 cents now i'm not a mathemagician
but that seems like about a dollar 20 to
me before the war so gas was raising
faster before the war than since the war
she doesn't say that of course because
now you know anything that happens here
guys if prices go up and you can't get
food and the supply chain's bad and some
other stuff's going on it's not because
of them it's that there's this guy putin
this putin guy he's doing some stuff
he's doing stuff
but saki continued to get pressed
because this is just so perfect
when you want to know what the swamp is
like what is the swamp really when
people talk about the swamp
and and this giant circle jerk that is
our political machine and our media
machine well it was announced over the
weekend that jen saki will be leaving
her job as white house press secretary
and where is she going to go
no not to a lobbying firm but that would
have been a good guess she's going to
msnbc does that seem ethical well she
was asked
is it ethical for you to continue
conducting this job
while
negotiating
with the media
well
i have always gone over and above the
stringent ethical and legal requirements
of the biden administration and i take
that very seriously and
as a standard for every employee of the
white house i have received rigorous
ethics counseling including uh as it
relates to any future employment i've
complied with all ethics requirements
and gone beyond and taken steps to
recuse myself from uh decisions as
appropriate
guys guys if ethics are here this girl
freaking
like she's like a male in a female
competition pole vaulting she just
just leaves everybody behind because
this is mrs ethics
okay this is complete nonsense this
woman all she has done for the last year
of her life is lie about absolutely
everything there there i don't think
there's anyone in america that has lied
more
she is the per capita winner for the
lying award okay
and what is she going to do what is her
reward
for that award her reward is to get a
job at msnbc so now msnbc is most likely
going to pay her a figure salary she
will probably make over a million
dollars a year that's a lot of cash to
just continue to lie on msnbc msnbc is a
propaganda network she just worked for a
propaganda president to now work at a
propaganda network as an analyst by the
way i'm sure that's what she's going to
be as an analyst they will i don't know
that they're giving her her own show
right off the top although that would be
propaganda in and of itself but they
will bring her on to analyze the news
and do you think that a woman
who uh just spent the last year lying
for administration an administration and
has all sorts of connections and friends
in that building the white house and in
the capital of those things do you think
she can honestly assess and comment on
what's going on there and by the way
this is not just about her this is what
they all do this is what they all do
george stephanopoulos the now chief head
of what is it abc news uh he was in the
bill clinton white house this is they
all go through all of these things
you're head of the dnc next thing you
know you're a cnn analyst you're a
failed political campaigner campaigner
next thing you know you're on msnbc news
the game that they are constantly
forcing us to play
we can see it we all see the rules now
and that's why so many people are
checking out that's why so many people
are watching this or watching the you
know the daily wire watching glenn beck
or watching whatever else people are
watching whatever the complete other
side of us are the lefty lunatic version
of me somebody's watching that and i
don't blame them because they even
realize how stupid mainstream media has
become uh and you know sake she's going
to bring you know her incredible insight
and her um
word trickery to msnbc here's what she
had to say about pregnant people what
beginning today as many as 720 000
pregnant and postpartum people across
the united states could be guaranteed
medicaid and children's health insurance
program coverage for up for a full 12
months after pregnancy thanks to the
american rescue plan
pregnant people pregnant people
these used to be known as women